الأمر المثير للاهتمام في هذا هو أن هذا
ليس من خلال وكلاء، وهذا ليس
حزب الله أو الحوثيين، بل هي إيران التي
تقوم بضربات جوية الآن على مجموعة من
الأهداف. ماذا ترى يحدث
هنا؟ حسنًا بالتأكيد جون أود أن أقترح
أن إيران أصبحت أكثر جرأة.
إنهم في الواقع يشنون الهجمات
بدلاً من وكلائهم، وأعتقد أنه
بالتأكيد رد فعل على ما
حدث في الصراع الدائر
بين الدول والغرب
وخاصة الولايات المتحدة، والهجوم الضخم
الذي شنته الولايات المتحدة ضد اليمن
الأسبوع الماضي.
وكذلك ما يعتبرونه هجمات سنية داخل
إيران تذكر ذلك الانفجار الذي
حدث قبل ما يزيد قليلا عن أسبوع
أه داخل إيران والذي أه
منسوب مباشرة إلى داعش لذا فهم
يمدون يدهم ويضربون أه
من يعتقدون أنهم سنيون
أهداف إرهابية في كل من أه في دمشق في سوريا
في العراق
وكذلك الآن في باكستان وهو أمر
مذهل بالنسبة لي وأنت تنظر إلى هذا
الجنرال هل هذا تعبير عن
القوة الإيرانية هل هذا يستعرضون ويحاولون
إظهار القوة أم أنه يظهر الخوف
والضعف أعتقد أن
كلاً من جون وما يجب علينا
مراعاته أيضًا هو أنهم يحاولون إثارة
مرجل مكثف للغاية من الديناميكيات
داخل الشرق الأوسط ويحاولون أن يكونوا
الطرف الإقليمي الذي يحاول إظهار أنفسهم
على أنهم الأقوى ولكن  أعتقد أنك على
حق، لقد أظهروا القليل من الخوف
عندما هاجموا داخل منطقة هيربال في
ذلك اليوم المنطقة الكردية التي تتمتع بحكم شبه ذاتي
وأعتقد أنهم كانوا
يحاولون إحداث نوع من الاضطراب
داخل الحكومة العراقية التي
تعلم أنها أنفقتها  قليل من الوقت
في شمال العراق أعلم أن
الحكومة الإقليمية الكردية أه
والحكومة المركزية العراقية لا يتفقان دائمًا
لذا حقيقة أن بعض
الأعضاء الأكراد في الحكومة العراقية
قالوا علينا
تحذير إيران  للتوقف عن القيام بهذا النوع من
الأشياء ثم تمضي إيران قدمًا وتشن
هجمات على باكستان التي تعد الآن
أيضًا مجرد حكومة مختلة ولديها
أيضًا أعداء مع الهند،
لذا فإن ما تراه هو
توتر متزايد في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط أه
شيء  أعتقد أن إيران
تواصل الإزعاج كما اعتادوا أن
يفعلوا ذلك مع الوكلاء الآن وهم
ينخرطون مع أنفسهم، ومرة ​​أخرى أعتقد أن هذا
يعكس شعورهم بأنهم
يمكن أن يكونوا أكثر جرأة قليلاً مع بعض
الأشياء التي تجري في المنطقة.  الشرق الأوسط
وخاصة في
غزة